.
Okay, Freunde der
Sonne, ich war in Vegas.
Und habe mein Geld verspielt.
Was soll das?
Aber eins nach dem andern.
Ich bin kein großer Casino-Fan.
Ich hatte bisher noch nie
das Bedürfnis, eins aufzusuchen.
Und, wie ihr wisst,
ich trinke keinen Alkohol.
Außer für wissenschaftliche
Demonstrationszwecke.
Deswegen war Las Vegas
nicht die Stadt meiner Wahl.
Aber es lag auf
dem Weg unserer Route.
Da dachten wir, das
schauen wir uns schon mal an.
Für wissenschaftliche
Demonstrationszwecke.
Es war anders, als
ich es mir vorgestellt hatte.
Zumindest die Casinos.
Bei Casinos dachte ich an
Glamour, wie in den Bond-Filmen.
Oder an eine gewisse
Stimmung, Aufregung, Spannung.
Dass Leute ihrem
Gewinn hinterherfiebern.
Das war aber eher selten der Fall.
Schätzungsweise 60-80 % der Casinos
bestanden aus Slot-Machines.
Aus diesen Einarmigen Banditen.
Die auch bei uns
in den Kneipen herumstehen.
Natürlich hat da alles
besonders schön geblinkt.
Aber so richtig glamourös oder
aufregend war das nicht wirklich.
Die Stimmung
war eher einsam und traurig.
Die Leute saßen alleine
vor den Slot-Machines.
Geradezu emotionslos.
Und sie haben wie
automatisiert gespielt.
Als würden sie
Fließbandarbeit machen.
Einen Psychologen würde
das jetzt nicht wundern,
denn Slot-Machines erfüllen alles,
was man für eine Spielsucht braucht.
Und auch viele
Social-Media-Plattformen
oder Handyspiele funktionieren
nach dem Prinzip Slot-Machine.
Deswegen dachte ich,
das schaue ich mir etwas genauer an.
Und wage einen kleinen Selbstversuch.
Erstmal habe ich mir
natürlich ein Geldlimit gesetzt.
20 $.
Ich weiß nicht,
wie weit man mit 20 $ kommt.
Weniger ist langweilig.
Dann wollte ich das Geld
in Spiel-Chips umtauschen.
Aber die brauchte man für
Slot-Machines noch nicht mal.
Let's play.
Das Spiel ist so simpel,
wie es nur geht.
Geld einschmeißen,
Knöpfchen drücken, Hebel ziehen.
Dann drehen sich die Räder.
Wenn ein bestimmtes Muster kommt,
hat man irgendwas gewonnen.
Man merkt nicht nur an
der Anzahl der Slot-Machines,
sondern auch an deren Aufmachung,
dass diese Maschinen das Glücksspiel
für jedermann sein sollen.
Um möglichst
verschiedene Leute anzusprechen,
gibt es Slot-Machines
in jedem erdenklichen Design.
Von klassischen
Aufmachungen mit Hebel
bis hin zu Breaking
Bad oder den Simpsons.
Aber im Prinzip sind alle gleich.
Und ich verliere einfach
nur ziemlich schnell mein Geld.
Ey, was soll das?
Oh, oh, sind doch ganz viele.
Wie kann das kein Gewinn sein?
Homer setzt mich unter Druck.
Wenn ich zu lange nicht spiele,
fängt er an zu schnarchen.
Wir haben schon elf Dollar verzockt.
Es hat bisher überhaupt
keinen Spaß gemacht.
Aber beim nächsten Automaten
sah das Ganze gleich anders aus.
Doch dazu kommen wir gleich.
Eigentlich ist so eine
Slot-Machine super langweilig.
Oder frustrierend.
Aber wenn doch ein Gewinn
rausspringt, freut man sich trotzdem.
Und wie das zu
einer Spielsucht führen kann,
das hängt mit
grundlegenden Funktionsprinzipien
unseres Gehirns zusammen.
Habt ihr das gemerkt,
(mit kurzem "i":) Gehirn.
Nicht (mit langem "i") Gehirn.
Ich lerne dazu.
Wir kommen jetzt zu grundlegender
Verhaltenspsychologie.
Sobald ich irgendwas gewinne,
bei der Slot-Machine,
Belohnung, ziehe ich den Hebel
wahrscheinlich noch mal.
Mit Hilfe von Belohnungen
lässt sich Verhalten antrainieren.
Wir werden konditioniert dazu,
den Hebel zu ziehen.
Oder auf das Knöpfchen zu drücken.
Bei Slot-Machines kommt
jetzt noch etwas Wichtiges dazu.
Wir wissen nicht,
wann die nächste Belohnung kommt.
Könnte beim nächsten Knopfdruck sein.
Könnte auch erst beim 100. sein.
Und wir wissen nicht,
wie hoch die Belohnung ist.
Es könnte ein Gewinn
von zehn Cent sein.
Oder von 10.000 $, die Belohnung
ist nicht voraussagbar.
Und genau
das macht besonders süchtig.
Verhaltenspsychologie
und Suchtpotenzial
wurden zunächst an Tieren untersucht.
Da wären zum Beispiel die berühmten
Experimente des Psychologen
B.F. Skinner an Tauben.
Stellt euch folgendes Experiment vor.
Ihr habt Tauben.
Die kriegen Futter, immer wenn
sie ein Signal an der Scheibe picken.
Quasi immer dann,
wenn sie ein Knöpfchen drücken.
Dadurch werden
die Tiere konditioniert,
die Scheibe zu picken.
Das Verhalten wird zu einem
wiederkehrenden Verhalten,
weil es mit Futter belohnt wird.
Aber dieses Verhalten kann
sehr unterschiedlich ausfallen,
je nachdem,
wie man die Belohnung gestaltet.
Man kann der Taube
nicht jedes Mal Futter geben,
wenn sie das Knöpfchen drückt.
Sondern nur manchmal.
Die Anzahl der Drücker,
nach denen sie Futter bekommt,
wird jedes Mal nach dem
Zufallsprinzip geändert.
Die Taube weiß also nicht,
wie oft sie drücken muss.
Um belohnt zu werden.
Dieses Belohnungsschema nennt sich:
Es sorgt dafür,
dass die Tauben viel
heftiger auf das Knöpfchen abgehen.
Bevor ihr jetzt sagt, sie
kriegen ja auch seltener Futter,
kein Wunder, dass sie mehr abgehen,
ganz so einfach ist es nicht.
Sagen wir, wir haben zwei
verschiedene Versuchs-Settings.
Setting eins, die Taube muss
zehnmal das Knöpfchen drücken.
Um Futter zu bekommen.
Also immer zehnmal.
Setting zwei, die Taube
muss verschieden oft picken.
Anzahl zufällig.
Aber im Schnitt kommen wir auch
auf zehnmal Picken pro Belohnung.
Am Ende bekommt sie in Setting
eins und zwei gleich viel Futter.
Wenn man die Zwei
vergleicht, sieht man,
dass die Tauben in Setting zwei
heftiger abgehen als in eins.
Die Tauben machen in Setting eins
nach jeder Belohnung eine Pause.
Das machen die hier nicht,
hier machen sie direkt weiter.
Wenn man den Tauben die Wahl lässt,
von welchem Apparat
sie sich Futter holen sollen,
von einem, der nach Setting
eins immer regelmäßig läuft
oder von einem, der nach
Setting zwei läuft, zufällig,
dann werden die Tauben
lieber das Surprise-Setting.
Tauben fahren also auf
unvorhersehbare Belohnungen ab.
Und wir Menschen auch, das
ist inzwischen gut untersucht.
Wobei B. F. Skinner schon den Bezug
zwischen Tauben und Spielsucht,
bzw. Slot-Machines herstellte.
Die Fähigkeit, aus
Belohnungen zu lernen,
hängt bei Tauben und Menschen von
dem Neuro-Transmitter Dopamin ab.
Dieses Molekül wird in
meinem Gehirn ausgeschüttet.
Sobald etwas passiert,
was ich als belohnend empfinde.
Bei der Taube sind
es die leckeren Körner.
Bei mir ist es der Jackpot in Vegas.
Unsere Gehirnzellen
haben Verbindungen,
die sogenannten Synapsen,
die Stärke dieser
Verbindung kann Dopamin ändern.
In diesem Fall führt es dazu,
dass das Verhalten, was ich
vor der Belohnung ausgeführt habe,
gestärkt wird, so bekomme ich Lust,
das Verhalten zu wiederholen.
Zum Beispiel, noch mal
auf das Knöpfchen zu drücken.
Diese Grundfunktionen unseres Gehirns
werden auch in anderen
Bereichen geschickt ausgenutzt.
Kostenlose Handyspiele zum Beispiel
leben nicht nur von Werbung.
Sondern auch von In-App-Käufen.
Deshalb sind diese Spiele,
etwa Candy-Crush, so gestaltet,
dass es unendlich viele Level
gibt, die man hochklettern kann.
Und mit jedem abgeschlossenen
Level ist es ein Belohnungsgefühl.
Dopamin wird ausgeschüttet,
man möchte es immer wieder haben.
So sehr, dass,
wenn man mal stecken bleibt,
man dazu bereit ist,
doch mal Geld auszugeben,
um ins nächste Level zu kommen.
Auch das Prinzip der unbekannten
Belohnung sieht man hier ganz oft.
In manchen Handy-Spielen kann
man Mystery-Booster-Boxen kaufen.
In Special-Sales,
wo man gar nicht genau weiß,
was man für sein Geld bekommt.
Auch Social Media
funktionieren nach dem Prinzip.
Der Never-Ending-News,
wird immer wieder aktualisiert.
Man kann stundenlang scrollen.
Selbst wenn nichts
Interessantes dabei ist,
hat man immer noch die Hoffnung,
dass der nächste Post
vielleicht lustig ist.
Oder der übernächste
oder auch der 100.
Slot-Machines und Spiele
nach demselben Prinzip
sind die Glücksspiele,
die am süchtigsten machen.
Deswegen ist es wahrscheinlich
gar nicht so erstaunlich,
dass Slot-Machines die Casinos
in Vegas so dominieren.
Ich hatte auch den Eindruck, dass
da die meisten Stammkunden sitzen.
Wir waren morgens schon
um 8.00 oder 9.00 Uhr hier.
Die Tables waren leer, aber an den
Slot-Machines saßen schon Leute.
Ich weiß nicht,
ob die schon da saßen oder noch.
Früher waren Slot-Machines noch
nicht ganz so addictive wie heute.
Früher gab es nur eine Gewinnszeile.
Wenn da dreimal die Kirsche kam,
hat man etwas gewonnen.
Das waren dann
seltenere, größere Gewinne.
Heute setzen die Macher
auf unzählige
verschiedene Gewinn-Kombinationen.
Auch viele kleinere Gewinne,
statt ab und zu mal was Größeres.
Das Prinzip der kleinen Gewinne
demonstriert mir diese Maschine.
Wenn die Asia-Slot-Machine mich
enttäuscht, dann weiß ich auch nicht.
Das ist meine Maschine.
Es dauert nicht lange, bis es blinkt.
Und ich etwas gewonnen habe.
15 Cent.
Aber dafür dauert es nicht lange,
bis ich wieder was gewonnen habe.
60 Cent.
Nicht so wenig, dafür,
dass ich immer nur 24 Cent setze.
Das ist ein guter Automat. Hier
gewinnt man ständig kleine Sachen.
Hier macht es tatsächlich etwas Spaß.
Weil das Spiel auch
nicht so schnell vorbei ist.
Und so richtig freue ich mich,
als ich bei der eigentlich letzten
Runde noch mal 60 Cent gewinne.
Was das Spiel dann wieder
um mehrere Runden verlängert.
Ich habe doch gesagt,
der Asia-Automat
wird mich nicht enttäuschen.
Natürlich weiß ich,
dass diese Gewinne
lächerlich klein sind.
Aber Dopamin
wird trotzdem ausgeschüttet.
Und dieses Suchtpotenzial zieht
den Leuten das Geld aus der Tasche.
Denn: Verlust garantiert.
Casinos sind ja ein Geschäftsmodell.
Bei allen Glücksspielen
wird hier sichergestellt,
dass am Ende des Tages mehr Geld
in die Maschine hineingeflossen ist,
als wieder rauskommt.
Wäre die Slot-Machine fair,
und ich würde
100 mal einen Dollar setzen,
kämen durchschnittlich
100 $ auch wieder raus.
Hier kommen aber nur
80 oder 90 % wieder zurück.
Da könnte man denken,
ich verliere nicht alles komplett.
Aber gerade die ständigen
Gewinne motivieren mich dazu,
immer weiter zu spielen,
und je länger ich spiele,
desto ärmer werde ich.
Zusammenfassend, wir haben 20 $
verspielt. 20 Cent gewonnen.
Das Ganze hat mit
Maschinen-Wechsel und Herumlaufen
vielleicht
eine Viertelstunde gedauert.
So geht es
letztendlich allen Spielern.
Doch das Suchprinzip
funktioniert trotzdem.
Und viele kommen immer wieder
zurück, um ihr Geld loszuwerden.
Also, hat mich jetzt
die Spielsucht gepackt?
Obwohl diese Belohnungssysteme unsere
grundlegende Psyche ansprechen,
haben verschiedene Menschen
verschiedenes Suchtpotenzial.
Zum Beispiel ist es nicht selten,
dass Menschen nach einem
traumatischen Erlebnis
einer Spielsucht verfallen.
Mich hat das
Experiment eher frustriert.
Ich habe nicht das Gefühl,
dass ich der Spielsucht ein kleines
Schrittchen näher gekommen wäre.
Zumindest hatte ich keine Lust,
jetzt noch mal zu spielen.
Mein erster Casino-Besuch wird
auch erst mal mein letzter sein.
Das ist auch das Einzige,
was ich euch raten kann.
Fangt erst gar nicht damit an.
Aber die 20 Cent Gewinn habe
ich mir noch auszahlen lassen.
Ich lasse mich hier
nicht über den Tisch ziehen.
Was ist mit euch?
Habt ihr Erfahrungen
mit Casinos oder Glücksspielen?
Oder gibt es irgend ein Handy-Spiel,
nach dem ihr süchtig seid?
Candy-Crush ist ein bisschen älter.
Es gibt doch bestimmt etwas Neues.
Schreibt es in die Kommentare,
wir sehen uns nächste Woche.
Das sollte dir nicht verpassen.
Denn es gibt ein Major Announcement.
So viel verrate ich schon mal.
Wir sehen uns.
Bis dahin, bleibt sicher.
Ohne das Video hätte
ich überhaupt nicht gespielt.
Ohne das Video
würde ich jetzt schon aufhören.
Ich habe keine Lust mehr.
Bisher bin ich eine
sehr frustrierte Taube.
So funktioniert das
Belohnungssystem bei mir nicht.
Es ist nicht,
was ich recherchiert habe.
Doch.
Oder sind diese
sieben Cent kleine Gewinne?
Soll ich mich darüber freuen?
Anscheinend.
Nichts gewonnen?
Sag mal, macht dir das Spaß?
Das macht doch keinen Spaß.